- So let's do some more
quotes from your book.
So this one's from Tina Fey,
I love her, and I love this quote.
"You can tell how smart people
are by what they laugh at."
(laughing)
- [Male guest] I live by that,
I mean on, when I'm on dates with people,
I always wanna know
what they think is funny
and what shows they watch.
- Yeah.
- And it's a great way
to figure out to me,
are we gonna be able to hang together?
- Yeah, it's very clever
way of picking the weeds.
- Yes, absolutely.
- Yeah, I'm not good at that,
I'm always like that person
that's like, oh, I don't know,
maybe they were an off day
or like maybe like the
(mumbles) I'm always like yeah.
- Yeah.
- I cut and run
- I should, we should
hang out. So it rubs off.
So wait, are you more, you
said you're a tea guy, right?
Not like a coffee garden,
but you like cocktails right?
- I love cocktails. Absolutely
- Have you ever tried alcohol and tea?
- [Male Guest] No.
- Okay. Like a hot toddy
isn't that kind of what a hot toddy is
- Yeah, kind of. No, I haven't.
- Oh, it's really good.
Anyway, well, this is, I
heard that you like cocktail.
So I thought that was,
that's a better first
date kind of thing too.
Cause then I feel like
people open up, right?
- [Male guest] Yeah, for sure
There's a Chelsea handler
quote in the book about,
about just that,
she's saying basically
denouncing coffee dates
and I totally agree. I
like a boozy first date.
So you let your guard down
and you kind of, when,
when you look at someone, I
know, well you, you have to,
well, you have to control yourself.
- Beer goggles are often
- Yes, exactly. Clear beer goggles.
- [Kelly] Do those exist
- I don't know.
- [Kelly] I don't know
I might be more of like a
coffee person to be like,
I don't know if I'm willing
to invest in like an evening
with you yet,
- [Male Guest] Right, yes
- Maybe like a 10:30, 11.
- [Male Guest] One drink
Yeah. Okay.